How's it going everyone? Some Muslims on
Tik Tok were asking for my home address
because, as they pointed out, they want
to Charlie Kirk me. Then a Dawa bro
named Malik, who's buddies with Shikman
and Jake Bronatella, doxed me and my
entire family and posted our home
address on Tik Tok. He even says he's
going to end me in Houston at Debatecon,
which is only a week away.
Did he would
Let's see how much longer you going to
last.
Time's running out.
Houston, huh, Papa? And his fans keep
saying they're going to Charlie Kirk me.
But now I'm confused because based on
what people are saying on X, we don't
even know what happened to Charlie Kirk.
Was he assassinated by some angry young
man named Tyler Robinson? Or was he
taken out by the agents who were
monitoring him after he traveled through
time to find Candace Owens?
>> Why did Charlie think he was a time
traveler? He said, as I showed you in
earlier messages, that he was a time
traveler and he had to find me.
>> I don't know, but I and my entire family
are being threatened. And these tick-
tock jihadis now know exactly where we
live. So I need to be as careful as
possible. Fortunately, careful is my
middle name. But because I'm so careful,
I want to get a better understanding of
what happened to Charlie Kirk. So I know
what these tick tock jihadis are
planning to do to me. Now, most of the
reasons people give for thinking that
Tyler Robinson didn't shoot Charlie Kirk
are stupid. People say it would have
taken a professional sniper to make that
shot. Okay, that's stupid. Any
10-year-old who's had some practice with
a 300 6 could make that shot. And Tyler
Robinson grew up in a gun family. He
could have made that shot with no
problem. But there is one objection that
I take more seriously. No exit wound. I
would definitely expect a shot from a
306 to leave an exit wound. Some people
are saying that the shot may have hit
Charlie's body armor first and then
bounced up to his neck. I don't know.
I'm assuming more evidence is going to
come out during the trial. But unless
something weird happened, like a
defective round or a ricochet or we've
just gotten some incorrect information
about the gun, this is going to sound
really weird to a lot of people. To show
you all what I mean, we're going to test
a few different types of guns to see
what they do to a target. I'm a
convicted felon, of course, so I'm not
allowed to fire or even touch a gun.
That's why I've got my friend Eric, your
brother in Christ, who's going to shoot
some targets. Now, we want to compare
the damage and penetration of different
types of rounds. And we want to quantify
this somehow. So, we'll use some things
we would ordinarily throw in the
garbage. Here [snorts] we have a
beautiful line of brand new Kurans.
We're going to test the penetration of
the 30 six much like 30 alut tested the
penetration of Muhammad.
All right. So check out what this round
from a 30 6 did. Went straight through.
One karan,
two kurons,
three kurons. Notice hole's getting
bigger. Look at that. Four.
Four karons.
Five
kurons.
Six.
Six Kurans.
Seven
Kurans. And stopped somewhere
in the seventh Quran here.
And
there it is.
And and that is why I would really
expect an exit wound from a 300 6.
Okay. So, we tested the penetration of
30 LZ. I mean 300 6. Now, for
comparison, we're going to try a 22.
So, that's what a 22 did. Now, notice
the difference. So, 22
and
looks like it went into
the second one, but not the third. So,
we'll see if we can find this here.
Actually, didn't even make it halfway
through.
And
there it is.
Didn't go through two kurons. Very big
difference between a 22 and a 30 six.
And we've got a line of fresh karans
here. We're going to test another rifle,
a 243.
So, right there in the eye on Sahi
International
went through one and notice the
difference here, guys.
Two.
Oh man.
Three,
four,
and stopped in number four.
Let's see what we got here.
And that broke up. So that's just a
little piece. And we've got some fresh
karans lined up. Sahi International.
We've tested three rifles so far. Now to
show you the difference, we're going to
test a couple of pistols. First up, 45
Hollow Point.
Okay, this one hit at the top.
This one hit at the top and then
so
kind of went in like that and then took
chunk out of that one. went through that
one and then looks like it was going
upwards and sort of went out and then
shot off somewhere else.
That's 45.
Going to test one more handgun. This is
a 44 Magnum Israeli Desert Eagle.
44 Magnum.
Two.
Three.
Four. Didn't go through
the fourth.
And
Actually, I see some fragments. See the
fragments there? Looks like it's split
up.
So, it's split up inside this somewhere.
There's the There's the major there's
the major debris.
So, we tested three rifles, two
handguns, and now by popular demand,
12 gauge slug.
Look at that.
Ow.
Well, I think we can say
based on the size of these holes
12 gauge slug is
the king of alot. So, it made some dents
beyond this, but I can see
I can see
the bulk of that slug.
No, that's some
that's not it.
Oh,
that's actually metal. There it is.
There it is.
Look at that.
That right there. Check it out.
And there you have it. Much like the alz
when they went into the desert for their
late night rendevous with Muhammad, a
300 6 is made for deep penetration.
You saw with your own eyes that a 300 6
went right through these Qurans like 30
zut went right through that walking
clown emoji who revealed these Qurans to
his gullible followers. So until I get
some more information to make sense of
all of this, I have no idea what these
Tik Tok jihadis are planning to do to
me. All I know is that I need to be
really, really careful. Please join me
in doing everything in our power not to
offend these scary, scary men. Let's
always remember to never disrespect
their amazing book or that child
molesting, murdering rapist they call a
prophet.
Don't miss all the action of me getting
Charlie kirked at Debatecon 7 in
Houston, Texas. Hope to see you there.